Done already.
Let's go to the solution.
In the menu layout file
for the main activity, called main.xml,
we add another menu item
that will always be in the overflow menu.
We also define the string
in the strings.xml file.
The menu will be inflated
in the main activity class,
so we can handle
the map menu item being inflated.
by calling helper method
called open preferred location in map.
The helper method reads the users
preferred location
from shared preferences.
Then we create a view intent,
indicating its location in the data URI.
The format of the data URI
was from the documentation
page on common intents,
where you can append
a postal code as a query parameter.
Finally, we start an activity
with this intent.
(typing)
Note that we only start the activity
if the activity resolves successfully.